Hello, sorry for being a little bit late today, everyone.
Oh my gosh, I swear to God.
I've been getting, like, messages, like, five to ten minutes right before my stream time, and, like, there are, like, messages where you're like, you have to answer them now, or it'll be too late.
I had, like, I had, like, two messages, two DMs from two different things, and then also an email that's a reply to, and I was like, I'm just about to start streaming!
I was awake since ten in the morning!
What do you mean?
What do you mean you can't send this to me earlier?
Oh, it wasn't even ten.
I was awake since nine in the morning.
By the way, Dad is, um, Dad is not here right now.
Um, I put him at the babysitter, or the dog sitter, because, like, I need some me time.
Like, I'm sorry.
I... Mommy needs some me time!
I can't.
I really... I want to...
I want to sleep in.
Sage, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you!
Good job.
Ganu, super chat, thank you, glad to see the zero depth run is going well.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you!
Yes, I'm still zero depth, guys.
So, happy Canada Day by the way.
It's debating on whether or not to do anything on Canada Day.
Like, you know, do stuff for myself.
Not for you guys.
Look, you guys have like two events already.
Do you really need a third?
Daddy needs some me time as well.
Like... We're so... I still have the birthday stream, Alan!
It's not just the concert.
We still have the birthday stream.
We're starving, Doki.
Anyway, so... Anyway, guys...
What do you mean you're starving?
I'm literally streaming on Canada Day.
Anyway, so I was debating whether... I'm doing two streams on Canada Day!
I'm debating whether or not to like actually go out during Canada Day to like, you know, enjoy Canada Day.
But you see, as you see on my schedule, I am currently doing two streams today.
Um... But also, the reason why was that... Um... Um... Was that because... Uh... Um...
Like... I know like, during these events, it's gonna be like, super fucking crowded.
And also like, I don't know.
Like, I don't know.
I've... And like, expensive food that isn't worth it.
Like, overpriced food trucks.
And... And...
So... I don't know.
I just... I feel like it's gonna be like, incredibly crowded anyway.
And like, um... Like, there's not gonna be like... I guess there'd be like, you know, bands playing and stuff like that.
But I feel like it's just gonna be like, so fucking crowded.
And like, it's just like, filled with people.
And like, food is gonna be overpriced and shitty.
And and so I was just like, ah, might as well just stay... Stay inside today.
I also went, I went to like a market.
Like, I went to like, a food market a couple of days ago.
I think like, on like, two to three days ago.
I went to like, a food market anyway.
And already it was... it was already, like, overpriced food and, like, uh, and overpriced shit.
I already had my experience that day of, like, what to expect for Canada Day.
So I figured, like, oh, man, like, you know, I don't have a fa... I don't, like, have, like, a family, uh, to do that with.
Or, like, anyone to really do, like, go out and, like, spend, like, spend too much money on things that, like, I might not need.
So I was just, like, uh, nah, I decided to stay in and stream today.
Uh, Zyko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, uh, Jakarta, thank you for the super chat.
Wait, Doki is Canadian?
But their birthday is literally 4th of July.
I'm getting mixed messages here.
Since when was Doki Canadian?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, I wrote, like, a couple of things I really want to talk about.
Oh, yeah, by the way, for those who saw my schedule at first, and it says Mecha Break at 5 p.m.
PST, it's actually gonna be at, um, tonight at 9 p.m.
PST, because that's when the servers go live.
Um, we both fucked up.
Me and the agent fucked up because, like, or the agent for the sponsor fucked up because we were like, okay, 5 p.m.
PST is the normal, usual time that she does her, uh, streams, like, the more primetime streams.
And they're like, okay, yeah.
And then later on, I read the briefing, and it was like, servers are gonna start at 9, like, servers are gonna be on at 9 p.m.
PST.
And I was like, wait a minute.
Because my manager was like, make sure to read the briefing, make sure to read it.
You know, like, he's been, like, pushing me to be more prepared for sponsors.
So I was just like, okay.
And then, you know, for once in my life, I read the briefing a day before the sponsor.
And then it literally said 9 p.m.
And I was like, wait a minute.
How come, how come this says, like, 9 p.m.?
But, like, I'm gonna stream tomorrow at 5 p.m.?
And then we're like, wait, that's, that doesn't seem right.
So then we're like, oh, and then the AJ was like, oh, sorry.
Sorry, we've, we missed that.
We missed it.
We, we, sorry, that was like, uh, um, misunderstanding slash, like, what is it called?
Uh, they misread something and, like, uh, and was like, oh, shit, sorry.
Yeah, server's gonna be up at 9 p.m.
So, yeah, you might have to move your stream to that time.
And I was like, oh, okay, well.
All right, 9 p.m.
PST, yeah, oversight.
That was an oversight from them.
So they're like, all right.
So that's why I was like, okay, guys, 9 p.m.
PST on Twitch.
We're gonna, uh, we're gonna play Mecha Break, which is great.
Because, like, I was gonna play it for free anyway.
So the fact that they came up to me and be like, hey, we'll pay you to play the game.
And I was like, oh, that's cool.
I mean,
The only downside is that I gotta be a little bit more family-friendly.
But, you know, but at least I don't get to play it for free.
Like, I...
So I was like, oh, shit, nice.
I was gonna play it anyway.
But, yeah, I get paid to play it.
Just gotta be a little more family-friendly than usual.
But, yeah, no, it's gonna be pretty exciting.
I heard a lot of good things above Mecha Break.
Uh, so I'm looking forward to trying out the game later tonight.
Um, also, um, I found out that, uh, because I didn't realize this, because I've been so busy, I actually haven't been, like, keeping up to date with Marvel Rivals.
But we're gonna have an extra stream this week for the early access, uh, for Marvel Rivals Season 3.
Uh, and that is, I believe, also on July 3rd.
Uh, so it'll be at, like, 4 p.m.
PST.
So it is an extra bonus stream.
Um, because I forgot about that.
I didn't even realize it was gonna be that soon, the early access, because the new season starts at July 12th?
I believe the newest season for Season 3 for Marvel Rivals starts at July 13th.
But, like, the early season preview starts at July 3rd.
So I didn't realize that.
So the only reason why I found out was because, uh, one of my friends was asking me, like, Oh, did you know the new hero?
What the new hero's gonna be?
I was like, no.
And he's like, oh, it's gonna be Phoenix.
And that was before, like, today got announced it was gonna be Phoenix.
So, like, they, like, leaked it to me.
And I was like, oh, I won't say who, because maybe.
But it's out anyway.
So I was like, oh, shit.
So then, like, yesterday, like, I was, it was leaked to me, like, a day early before, uh, the Marvel Rivals thing will be on YouTube.
Um, but basically, they leaked it to me, like, a day before it got announced, which is today.
So I got, I knew about it yesterday.
Or the, no, I knew about it two days before they announced it.
So, um, um, so I was like, oh, shit, okay.
Uh, no, I didn't hear about it.
And then they're like, oh, yeah, they're gonna be doing the season preview soon.
And I was like, oh, shit.
So then I messaged my Marvel Rivals person.
I was like, hey, can I be, like, in the other, the newest preview, the next streamer preview event?
Because, I know, I was like, oh, I'm gonna do it anyway, but it'll be cool if I get paid for it.
I didn't say that.
But I was like, you know, I shot my shot, you know?
Always shoot your shot, you know?
My goal is so, you know, the worst thing you can say is no.
So I was trying to shoot my shot and be like, oh, hey, can I, like, um, you know, be invited to, to the next preview for it?
Because I heard that, like, you know, the new season's coming out.
So that means the new preview's coming out.
And they're like, oh, so I already selected the streamers.
Um, but, like, you know, if anybody can make it, we'll, we'll have you in mine.
And then I was like, oh, it's okay.
But then, like, I still have the general streamer.
I just don't get paid for it.
But that also means I can stream it on YouTube, you know?
Yeah.
So, um, so there's two things, one, two versions.
There's one where it's like the early streamer preview, where they get it earlier than the general preview, early access.
So general early access, no one gets paid to test it out.
But the, the, the real streamer access, people get, we get paid for that.
So it's sponsored.
And you're playing with other content creators, you know, like other big content creators and other streamers.
Like, like when I did the one last time, I got in my, I got invited with like huge content creators, like ones that are in like Kaisenats groups and stuff like that.
Like people who were in the Kaisenat group or like, um, um, and like, uh, the really, really big content creators that has like millions and millions of followers and stuff.
So like, um, there's that one and you get paid to do that.
And they get the early access two hours before the general early access.
So I was like, eh.
And then they were like, sorry, we already selected our streamer.
So I was like, oh.
I was like, ah.
But I still have the general early access, which I don't get paid to do, but I get to be on YouTube.
That's two hours after the streamer preview.
So we're gonna... It's like 4 p.m.
PSC.
So we'll... Yeah, it was worth the try, you know?
It was worth the try.
Like I said, it doesn't hurt to shoot your shot, you know?
It doesn't hurt.
The worst thing to say is no.
And they said no, but they were like, we'll keep you in mind for the next one.
Like for other events.
I was like, yippee!
But yeah, there was that.
And so an extra stream on the 4th.
Oh, sorry, not the 4th.
On the 3rd.
An extra stream on the 3rd at 4 p.m.
PSC for the new Marvel Rivals early access for Phoenix.
For Phoenix.
And it's gonna be on YouTube.
That one's not gonna be on Twitch.
The Mechabrick stream will be on Twitch, though.
It's crazy.
A lot of the sponsors have been lately going towards Twitch rather than YouTube.
Because of like Twitch drops.
And because there's, you know, Twitch drops is easier for Twitch drops.
And they want to boost the category up for the viewer count.
Because, you know, they're sponsoring a lot of people.
And usually it's more so of like, they want the category to be like higher.
So a lot of them tend to not want it on YouTube.
I found out, other than Gacha, Gacha is mostly on YouTube because like, I guess it's more so like, I guess it's like more so of like, it's, Gacha tends to not have Twitch drops.
So like, they're more okay with it be on YouTube and even, and it is like where majority of my audiences are.
So I thought that was really interesting.
But a lot of, a lot of games that are non-Gacha tends to want me to stream on Twitch due to like, you know, the category and, uh, and like Twitch drops.
So it's like, it makes more sense.
So it's like, when I was sponsored by Marvel Rivals, they also wanted me to be on Twitch as well because of like Twitch drops plus the category.
Um, yeah, so, speaking of Gacha game, my fucking Twitter feed is all about the goddamn horse game.
Um,
like, I knew that game is really popular, was already really, really popular in Japan, but like, it recently hit, like, the servers, uh, English servers recently went live, um, in N.A., and everybody is fucking playing it and talking about it.
And like, I, um, I was curious because I was like, okay, um, but it was like, I don't, there's no gameplay.
Like, I'm sorry, but I, I like, like, one of my friends was trying to, trying to convince me, I was trying to, there is, you're blind.
Um, but, they tried to convince me, and I was, I was literally just, wait, we're, wait, are we just watching?
Oh, I understand that they're making a lot of money.
I understand the Gacha purposes of the game, but I was like, wait, oh,
I understand what gameplay you guys are talking about.
But, it has, Lord, Doki, you gotta read it, it's not, it's not just about the game, Doki, it's about raising your horse so she can be the idol that she was meant to be.
Is that it, guys?
Is it, is that it?
Okay, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, Doki, think of it this way.
Uma Musume, pretty derby, is a roguelike horse training simulator with cute girls, thank you for this super chat, thank you, thank you.
No name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But where's the gameplay?
Gameplay?
And then, but like, I was watching like the horse racing part.
And, um, I thought it was, like, it's just, it's just legal horse...
It's legal horse racing.
So like, you can, you can play it no matter what age.
And it's all legal.
Um, it still has the, uh, it still has the debt ramifications of horse betting.
You could potentially go broke just like horse betting.
But instead of, you know, going to the derby and watching it on TV.
You watch it on your monitor, on your PC or your phone.
Yeah, no Yakuza to worry about.
And you can bet on your favorite horse girl at any age you want.
Now you get it!
Because when I was watching, I was like, oh shit, this is like basically actual horse racing.
But they just swapped, they just turned them into anime horse girls.
Uh, GoldenFoxy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, since horse racing is another form of gambling, it makes sense.
Gotcha.
Like it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, uh, but yeah, I thought, I thought that.
I know like, like my friend was like, you should play on stream.
I was like, I'm not gonna play, I'm sorry guys.
I'm not gonna play on stream.
And I know for sure they'll never sponsor me for this.
Because they make enough money right now off of NA.
They're, they're, they're, they're, they're, they're, they make enough money in NA.
And obviously, they do not need extra publicity.
Uh, Cindy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm subscribing because I'm not gonna play the hoist girl game.
I, you know I won't, you know I won't spend money on this guys.
You know I, I won't spend money on it.
Um.
Hi Doki, did you find 11 other members for your B12 music video?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my God, you know who like instantly showed up in my DMs.
When I, when I tweet, someone instantly showed up in my DMs when I, when I tweeted about it.
I, I won't say who, but she was very, very into actually wanting to make this a reality.
That's all I'll say.
uh.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Uh.
Uh... Apparently, she has been like, obsessed with the, the song, like, B12 for, yeah, she's been obsessed with that song for a while now.
And ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
And she's like, if you are serious, I want in.
And I was just like...
Because obviously, my intentions for making that tweet was originally as a shitpost.
But, like, a lot of people were actually so, like, really wanted to make that real.
I was very surprised that, like, that tweet, like, blew up.
Because I've been shitposting the last couple of days.
So I was very surprised.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You have to do it now.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But, yeah, I'll just say that her hair was pastel.
Of a pink variety.
Anyway...
What else did I want to say?
There was something else I wanted to talk about.
Buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh.
Fuck, what was it?
Also, I'm really sad.
I'm really mad that Pom Pom Perun won the Sandoval contest.
That fucking whore.
That...
He only won because he showed his ass.
And you all know it.
You all know it.
He was fucking flying that shit everywhere during the Sani World contest.
Fuck that dog.
My dog should have won, guys.
My dog should have won.
Not that dog.
My dog.
Don't hate the player.
Join that booty around.
Goddamn slut.
No, he has to win all the time.
He deserves it.
He's the people's dog.
He did what he had to do.
RMD.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Perfect opportunity to stream Barbie horse adventures.
Get a competing horse girl game narrative going.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The fact that... Okay, what was it even worse?
Like, where the fuck did Pochaco come from?
I was like, who the fuck?
I was like, who the fuck wrote it for goddamn Pochaco?
Where the fuck did that guy come in to get third place?
I was so surprised.
I was like, where's my queen, Kuromi?
Uh, do no one like goth girls anymore?
What happened?
Oh, where did he come from?
Like, Pochaco came out of nowhere with a goddamn chair.
Uh, Pochaco fat here.
None of this Pochaco.
He is a generic dog.
It's not even that special.
Uh, that's right.
I'm coming for all of you guys.
I...
Um...
The two Pochaco fans in chat.
I was just like, I can't believe...
Where did Pochaco come from?
Like, I... He was never popular and then suddenly he is third?
I was so surprised.
I was like, how did he become third?
He was never popular in the first place.
I don't understand.
He is...
He is special in my eyes.
I am very passionate about this.
Also, um, I forgot to mention about the concert.
Uh, uh, you're so good at social media, Doki.
Powerful.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I...
The...
I don't know what got into me.
Every time I actually, like, want to do something on social media, I just pop off.
I...
I just...
It's like, I just shitpost, like, once or twice a year.
Like, like, once or twice, maybe, like, every two to three months.
I just shitpost, like, tweet, like, one or two things.
And then it pops off.
And then I disappear.
I...
I just...
I disappear after that.
Back to just retweeting.
And tweeting out my waiting rooms.
And I'm like, oh shit, speaking of that, let me be, like, live now.
Uh, don't slander my boy Pochaco.
He came out of nowhere!
He's been, like, bottom of the leaderboards for fucking years!
And then, like, suddenly he's third place?
Like, what the fuck?
Okay, that is...
That's, like, an inside job or some shit.
Okay, anyway, let me type, live now.
Live now!
All right.
All right, there we go.
Um, yeah.
I thought...
What was that?
Oh, yeah, the concert.
By the way, okay, so...
I talked about this in member stream.
But if you were going to...
Sorry, there's a lot of updates.
Sorry, guys.
But if you were going to...
Anime Expo.
All right.
So, this is not just a blob.
Okay, so...
So, here is the venue for...
Um, Anime Expo.
The concert.
Which, by the way, I'm so fucking tired from...
From planning this and preparing for this.
I am so tired.
There's so much going in.
Anyway.
As you can see, there is no...
If you were going to Anime Expo concert...
The best seats are not the center.
If you want to watch the concert itself...
It's the side seats right here.
If you're...
You got the front row...
You have to get these seats right here.
Like, uh...
Like...
Sorry.
These seats right here are the best seats.
Because there is the screen.
Because, um...
The side seats are meta.
It's not the center seats.
Uh...
It's the side seats.
So, if you're going to Anime Expo for my birthday concert...
Um...
On July 3rd...
You get the side seats.
The reason being is that...
We try to make it...
Get the center screen.
Um...
Uh...
The Watage people will be here on this stage.
You can see here.
Right here.
That's where the Watage people will be at.
Performing.
Right here in the center.
So...
The reason why...
Uh...
We don't have a center screen.
We try...
We asked Anime Expo...
If we could...
Um...
We could get a center screen.
Because it's going to be like, you know...
A...
A VTuber concert.
And they were like...
Yeah, you can.
You can.
Absolutely.
We're fine with that.
And then we asked the Fire Marshals...
And the Union.
And they said no.
Now, I'm not against Unions.
But I...
Disclaimer.
I'm not against Unions.
But...
I was like...
Why the fuck am I not allowed?
That was...
There's like...
10...
20 plus...
Exits.
I was like...
Why the...
What would the center...
Like...
Why is it...
Why can't we have a center screen?
And they're like...
Apparently...
We were told that...
And we were told about this like...
The last couple...
Of days.
Like...
It was like the last couple days ago...
That we were told about this super last minute.
Um...
Stop slut-shaming Pruitt just because you're Oshi lost.
What a shame, Toki.
Loli, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Anyway, they were saying that it's too much work.
And there's too much work and like, you know, potential for fire.
And I was like, how the fuck would that happen?
I was just like, okay, I was like, but we'll pay for it.
And they're like, we literally said we'll pay for it.
That's what we told them.
That we will pay for it.
I mean, look how I can count the exits.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20, 21.
There's like, I don't know, I might have counted more than one.
There's like at least 20 exits.
So because of that, um, we're trying to figure out solutions, um, we're trying to figure out solutions on like what to do for the center screen because we already put so much work into this concert, like money wise and like practicing and everything for it.
I'm so tired.
So I'm so tired.
And so, um, so they're like, you can't, you can't put us, you can't rent a center screen or anything because of it.
So we're like, okay, then, and then me and my staff were like, what do we do?
Anyway, uh, anyway, so I was, I suggested at first we're like, oh, we could have like displays and stuff like that.
Like cutouts, like live, like giant stands on me and then get cosplayers and stuff like that.
And then I was like, what if we get, uh, Watage people there, like, you know, performing to the song since we have the center stage open, you know, like, it's literally there, like, it's open, it's a blank area.
So they're like, we're like, so then it was super last minute.
We actually got confirmation yesterday night on like whether or not they could like come because like it was incredibly last minute and everything.
So they're like, yeah, we can do it.
We can do that since they're already heading to, and the best, the great thing about it was that they're already heading to Anime Expo as well.
So like, it was just convenient timing for us and them because, uh, they were already heading there.
So like, it's just like, you know, something they could do while they're there already.
So, um, so they're going to be performing on the center stage alongside the concert where they gave them the set list and everything.
So they know what song is going to be.
So they are going to be preparing for that.
And yeah, so it's something extra for those who are going to the concert.
It's just, you know, an extra experience.
When the video, when the vibe of the concert itself is going to be on my channel later, obviously you guys won't see the Watage things.
Because that's like on the venue.
So this is like a little extra something for those who are there at Anime Expo.
So, yeah, but anyway.
Yeah, so I hope everybody will enjoy the Anime Expo concert.
For those who can't make it, don't worry.
The video of the concert, of the performance itself, will be published on my channel at a later date when we refine it more.
I just need you guys to remember that this concert was literally done in less than a month.
Actually no, we had just a month to do all of this.
So, it was crazy.
Like, usually concerts take a lot more time.
Especially with like songs, choreo, dancing, motion capture, production.
That is like, it's crazy.
I managed to do all of this with a team of people in a month.
So, we gotta, we have to polish it.
We have to polish it after its debut at Anime Expo.
Because like, today, um, we're going through stuff today.
And I was like, okay, here, like, state the stuff I want to fix on like, the concert stage and stuff like that.
And like, the lighting and stuff.
And they're like, yeah, we could do some of this.
But like, we can't do all of this because we have two days left.
So, I was like, it's fine.
We'll, we'll do this after the anime.
We'll fix the stage after Anime Expo.
Like...
Please, girl, you gotta stop doing this yourself.
Thank you, Super Chat, JL.
Thank you, thank you.
Just remember, I'm doing this.
Plus, I'm prepping for something special on the birthday itself as well.
So, a lot of stuff is going on.
Because, um, we're also, I also have stuff I'm doing for my actual birthday stream.
Not just the concert.
So, it's like, all like, condensed into the...
This week is crazy.
I'll just say that.
This week is fucking crazy.
It's, it's a lot.
It's definitely, um, a lot of stuff going on right now.
Anyway, let's actually play Elden Ring.
Sorry.
We had a very long, very long tangent today.
So, let's actually get Elden Ring booted up.
Um...
No, I'm definitely...
After my birthday week, I'm gonna take it a little, um...
A little, um...
Like...
A chiller week after the birthday week.
Because of everything that led up to the birthday week.
It was a lot.
It was fucking a lot, guys.
Uh...
Dango, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
My health still won't allow me to go to things like off-kind meet and greets.
Even though I live down the street from the center or AX.
So, this super chat is how I show my support.
Thank you for the super chat.
Dango, thank you.
Thank you.
I'm very appreciative.
I hope...
Um...
Your health recovers.
I really appreciate it.
Yeah.
No.
You will understand.
When...
Um...
When you see...
When I talk about the concert.
You'll understand.
I mean...
The fact that I got a concert made within a month is already pretty fucking crazy.
But, you'll understand when I go into detail about this goddamn concert, you'll... I will leak secrets that they won't tell you... Not won't, but like, usually people don't talk much about how concert planning goes into it, along with like, the motion capture.
And the price!
Okay, I will review how much it fucking costs!
Like, I'm... I...
And like, apparently, by the way, apparently, what I spent on my concert is cheaper than like, how it usually costs, if you like, get it done in Japan.
Because my studio is a Chinese studio.
And apparently, I was, I was like, swapping notes with someone else who's, um... With someone else who works with like, Japanese 3D studios.
And mine... Was a lot cheaper.
And mine was already very expensive.
I was like, holy fuck!
I... Dookie, are you having, uh, Wotage performers with planned choreo?
Or just fans doing... No, they're, they're an actual group.
Uh, they have my set list, so they're planning something around it.
But thank you for the super chat, JP.
Thank you, thank you.
They're like, an actual... Professional group that does it.
Um... That does it like, quite often for like, other... Uh, places.
Like, other... They did like a performance in OffGuy.
Uh, so, yeah.
Um... Alright, where do we go?
I'm so fucking lost.
Where... Do we go here?
I went to... I went to Chinese studio, because, um... Um...
Because, like, um... It was based off of, like... Gacha games.
And, like, how their mocap is done.
And the 3D for gacha games and mocap.
So, I was like... I felt like, um... Now, recently, like... The technology for it.
For, like... Chinese, like, gacha games.
And 3D technology.
Is, like, super good.
So, I... Oh, this tree?
Okay.
So, I went... So, that's why I went with a... Uh, with a Chinese studio.
And also, like... I could speak to them.
You know?
Like... I could communicate with them better.
Yeah.
They definitely... Um... I feel like the motion capture in, like, 3D got a lot better.
Too.
I wonder how... How do I make it so I use 2?
Do I do, like... How do I make it so I use 2?
Okay.
So, it's L... Yeah.
So, I have... I'm trying to, like...
Oh, my god.
I'm trying to use this sword.
Okay.
Alright.
This is the first time using this sword.
So, the double katana.
Alright.
Oh, that's good.
I spoke Canto.
I speak Canto.
But, like, I can hear Mandarin.
And... And, like, I can speak a little bit of Mandarin.
And also, um...
Um... And also, I have staff members that can speak Chinese.
And also, they speak English.
In the end, I... They also speak English.
So, like, I didn't need all that anyway.
Uh...
In the end, the staff ended up speaking English to me.
So, that was nice.
I didn't have to, uh, get a translator at all.
That... That helped a lot, you know?
Like, I was prepared.
They grabbed, like, staff and stuff and everything.
But, in the end, they also speak English as well.
So, that... That helped.
Um...
I remember when I was, like...
I was, like, scouting out for 3D Studios.
I had to add, like, a Japanese translator to help me with, um...
To help me with, like, communicating with the JP Studios.
But, uh, when I went for...
I... When I looked for a Chinese...
Like, when I, you know, look at my various options...
That was also the only reason why I picked the studio.
Because they also speak English.
So, I was, like, oh, that's cool.
I don't...
You know?
I was, like, oh, that's cool.
Thank God.
So, there's no, like, miscommunication and stuff.
Uh...
Alright.
That's stuff.
And I'm just going forward.
Am I...
I need to double check something.
To make sure the graphics are okay.
Uh...
Yeah.
It's portless, window, advanced settings.
Okay.
I don't know if I...
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Give me a sec.
I know what to do.
It's gonna save.
Feels a little off.
Okay.
That should be better.
Alright.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm gonna yell at you.
So, I'm sending this for more womanbird tomato thing.
Why do you spend so much money to make us happy?
Because...
YOLO.
Haha.
Thank you for the super chat, Darkblade.
Thank you.
YOLO.
You know?
I don't know how long I'm gonna be...
this...
popular...
I guess?
I don't know when exactly.
OH my God!
He...
Holy shit!
He slam tucked me!
I don't know how long I'm gonna be, like...
Um, oh my god.
Until I fall off, so I'm making the best out of it.
I wanna know, like, how much... how much does he give?
Oh my god, this fucking guy who slam dunked me.
How much was that?
Wait, that's... I don't even know how much he gave me there.
I never saw it coming, to be fair.
I never...
That's right.
You wanna ban me?
Get out of here.
Oh wait, there's a map right here.
That's actually what we needed.
Oh, that's really good.
Also, like, I watched an Elden Ring playthrough.
Uh, well, it wasn't necessarily an Elden Ring playthrough.
Okay, since playing Elden Ring, I'm getting recommended a lot of fucking Elden Ring videos.
But they have the most clickbaity goddamn titles that they always get me.
They always fucking get me.
They always get me to goddamn click the video, and they know it.
Anyway, so, one of the video was like...
I saw, it was like, um...
I beat Elden Ring by only level one stat.
And it's like, strength.
I was like, bro, what the fuck?
So I was like, bro, that can't be.
How the fuck did this man fucking beat Elden Ring?
Love that one stat.
And it's strength.
And he's like...
Ungabunga.
Me...
Me pound you with hammer.
Because he carries, like, a giant...
Goddamn.
Oh my god, I missed the bird.
He is...
I missed the third bird.
God fucking damn.
And...
Gronk.
Kill.
Like, big bonk.
And...
He is like...
It was like...
All strength.
And it was literally, like...
Fucking...
With giant ass armor.
With no...
A giant ass hammer.
Goddamn...
Um...
There was no fucking stats on anything else.
And he wasn't wearing armor, too.
Um...
He's just...
He's like...
Grog smash.
Anyways, so...
I will...
That video popped up.
And I was like...
Are you fucking...
And then...
What pissed me off the most...
Was that...
He beat the entire fucking game...
In...
Eight hours.
With less than a hundred deaths.
Like...
Oh my god.
That's...
That's what pissed me off the most.
Oh hey, it's two...
It's a witch.
Uh...
The...
Two...
Two toes.
Um...
Hahaha.
I was like...
Are you...
Fucking kidding me?
He...
All he had was strength!
And he fucking won the game!
In...
Less than...
Eight hours!
No armor!
What about my fingers?
Yeah?
We're gonna see my hands?
Thank you.
Is this...
Is this a fetish thing?
Ruins of gold...
To the west...
The serpent's sacrilege...
Wherever the path leads...
So shall you follow...
Only more...
Oh!
She's telling me where the story bosses are.
Tis a curse...
A curse...
You okay, ma'am?
The curse of...
Queen...
Marika!
Oh no...
Have you ever thought about...
Not being sad?
More?
What?
Why do you want to see more of my fingers?
Oh no, that's... one is enough.
You got to pay for the second time.
You were... Okay, so...
Guys, she just cured the... Yeah, have you ever thought about not being sad?
Also, like, another one that popped up in my recommended was one where it was like...
There was a mod where you can just have a gun.
And I was this close...
I was this fucking close to installing that mod...
But I found out that you have to restart your game if you...
Like, like, I literally wanted to start today's playthrough with, like, just a gun...
There's, like, it's basically a mod where you have a gun...
And a tank...
And a...
And a fighter jack...
And a fucking nuke...
And I was...
And I was this close...
And I saw, like, a playthrough of that...
And I was this close to, like, installing that mod today...
Like, for today's stream...
And just started out with...
Just like, hey, guys...
So now I have a gun...
I...
It was...
I was so close, guys...
I was all...
I saw...
I was like, oh my god...
I could have a gun right now...
Xanatos...
Xanatos, thank you...
Five gifted...
Of my ships...
Thank you, thank you...
Xanatos, thank you, Superchild...
Today's a special day...
And I want to share it with you all...
That is right...
It is my birthday...
Happy birthday, Xanatos!
Happy birthday to you...
Happy birthday, dear Xanatos...
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Yay!
I have a great birthday.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's a good thing you didn't because unless you use a seamless co-op or offline, the mod would have instantly banned your Steam account.
No more phrases.
Yeah, but I couldn't have a... I couldn't have a gun though, guys.
Oh, did I go the wrong way?
That's... that's alright.
I can just teleport back.
That's alright.
For he's a jolly good fellow.
Ba dum ba dum ba dum.
If only I had a gun.
Shogun.
Alright, lump of flesh.
Where the fuck do I go now?
I'm so lost.
Alright.
Okay, this is a giant hill.
Go down here.
I think I could.
I can make it.
Oh, yeah.
There you go.
Okay.
That was... that was bait.
It just seemed like I made it.
That was... I was like, oh shit.
Yeah, I did it.
Okay, that... that was fucking bait.
Cause it like... it looked like I made it at the end.
And then I touched the last area.
The last floor.
I knew gravity.
It felt like... I don't know.
It felt like I just lived for some reason.
Alright.
The bats are back, guys.
Oh my god.
That was a giant ass bat there that killed me.
Chat.
Um... Sydney, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Joki's modern warfare build.
Firing RPGs at the stupid snake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Where the fuck do I go?
There has to be a bottom somewhere.
Okay, I'm getting... I'm getting horse out.
Horse, tell me where to go.
Maybe down here?
What the fuck?
Yeah, there it is.
But like, how do I get there?
Where does that go?
Oh, it's here.
Okay, I found it.
Okay.
I'm curious about these guys.
Okay, I might be... Okay, there we go.
Okay, I'll do here and then we'll go from here.
Alright, we figured it out.
Guys, we found the bottom.
Okay.
Alright, there we go.
I figured it out.
I did a flip.
And everything.
Alright, and then...
We should be able to head to the giant ass...
Fucking tree.
Right?
Is the tree over here?
Wait, where did the tree go?
Wait, where did the big ass...
Oh, the tree's to my right.
Okay, we're going this way now.
Uh...
Okay.
Okay, the tree's above me.
Okay, we went...
Alright, we went the wrong way.
We went...
Guys, the tree was apparently above me.
Guys.
Alright.
Maybe...
Guys, maybe there's a way here.
Guys, I...
This is not a filler episode, guys.
I swear to God.
We're...
We're past the filler episode.
Okay, but there's another tree here, though.
What about the tree above me?
What about this tree?
Is there anything special with the tree up here?
Wait, I don't like how there's health beetles around here.
I don't like that.
Oh.
He's pretty big.
Oh, my God.
Are you okay, buddy?
Okay, he seems pretty sick, too.
I...
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, wait.
These are little guys.
Wait.
Is that guy a boss?
Okay, let's find out.
I'm curious.
Oh, worm face.
Yeah, he is.
Okay.
And he has...
Okay, that's not fair.
He has friends.
That's not fair at all.
Oh, and he's poison.
Oh, wait.
And he's weak.
I got this, guys.
I got this.
He's weak as fuck.
Okay, that's not what I meant to do.
I got this.
Look at him slowly walking up to me.
Like, what is he gonna do?
Look at that.
Oh!
Okay.
I...
Now I know.
Now I...
Okay.
I know now.
Alright.
Now that I know what he can do.
It's...
It's over.
I know now, guys.
I know what he can do.
Okay.
Guys.
I know what he can do.
So, like...
Oh, my God.
Wait, I think... I think that's a tree.
Oh, I think this is gonna turn me into a tree man.
Wait.
Wait, there's tree men all over him.
Oh, no!
No!
I don't wanna be a tree!
Ah, I'm okay!
I'm not okay.
Guys, I'm not okay.
That's insane!
Instant!
Why is that instant?
Holy fuck!
Okay, that's illegal.
I am Groot.
Where's my fucking... Where's my... Is that it?
Is that where I died?
Oh, that is where I died.
Holy shit, I died so far.
Okay, I figured it out, though.
I am Groot.
Okay.
I figured it out.
Um... Guys, um... Oh... Okay.
Oh my god.
Guys, I don't wanna fight him anymore.
Actually, don't... Actually, I think I'm done fighting.
Oh, shit!
Where did he come from?
Okay, let me... Okay, let me... Let me get this down real quick fast.
Let me...
Okay, wait.
Let me figure this out.
Okay.
Yes!
Oh!
Oh my god.
He just... He, like, fucking just spit at me and it was over.
Like, what was I supposed to do?
Where's my... Where's my thing?
Okay, there it is.
Alright, let me grab my... Okay, we're leaving.
Okay, I realized that he's not weak, guys.
Alright, now that I know that that was a mistake, I go now.
How can message appraisal save me?
Okay, we'll go this way.
We'll go this way now.
Alright, here we go.
How will this message appraisal save me?
How can it save me from instant death?
Blackfire, thank you for the five gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you.
Holy shit.
Okay, I just need you to know...
Um...
Oh my god.
I'm at 80% CP right now.
Okay.
We'll follow the road.
If only I had a gun, guys.
If only I had my fighter jet.
Alright.
My only issue is that, you know I'm mad.
I'm gonna beat you guys up.
I'm mad.
That's fucking right.
Okay.
Get outta here!
That's right!
I let my anger out on the little guys.
But...
You were the Canadian one, Doki.
You were meant to chop down the trees, not join them.
Danny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh shit.
Okay, that's fine.
And then...
Whoops.
That's fine.
I don't care about these jets.
Oh.
That's fucking right.
You think I care?
I have nine pots.
Yeah, you can...
Come on!
Hit me again!
I like it!
Yeah, you think I care?
That's right, you're gonna die anyway.
There we go.
I can brute force that.
That's fucking right.
Brute force time.
Let's go.
Alright.
We go...
It should be like...
This way?
And then up this rock?
The fuck?
Why do I get up there?
How do I get up there?
Do I go this way?
Do I go to that giant bridge?
Or do I...
Oh, I can climb up these rocks.
Wait, but I can go up these rocks, though.
Does this work?
Okay, this does not work.
JK.
This doesn't work, guys.
God, I'm so lost.
Guys, it's not the...
Oh wait, look.
NPC.
Nice.
Free stuff.
Give me...
Give me free stuff first, though.
Hello.
Oh, Earth Tree.
Great Earth Tree.
The Golden Order itself.
Unwavering stretch to the sky.
Confere your guidance to our Elden Lord.
You put this worry world to rights.
Okay, where's my fucking free shit, buddy?
I'm not your buddy, guy.
Alright.
Get out of here.
Give me your shit.
Oh, just cause you have a big arrow.
You think I'm scared?
AHHHHH!
Guys, can you...
Can you get your big arrow back?
Oh, shit.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I...
Your big arrow was so cool.
It was so cool, though.
I'm sorry.
It...
It was so cool.
I'm sorry.
It...
I...
AHH!
It was so cool.
I peed it.
Carilla's strengths.
It's okay.
I can't...
I got my stuff.
City ahead.
Oh, this way.
Oh!
This way.
Okay.
You do this to yourself.
I don't know.
I thought he was gonna still have the giant ass arrows.
I'd be like, fucking stupid.
What are you gonna do?
Oh, shit!
Oh my god, I didn't see the crossbowers.
Yeah, I'm fucking getting torn in here.
I'm getting my horse in here.
Wait, Grace, am I right?
Oh, shit, I like that.
I like Grace.
Where is it?
Where the fuck is the Grace?
Where the fuck is the goddamn Grace?
Oh my god, he said right!
Oh, sorry, you're right.
Sorry, you're right, not my right.
Alright, let me go the other right.
Alright, let's go to find the Grace again.
They have enough for a level up, I'm pretty sure.
Yeah?
Where the fuck is the Grace?
Where is it?
No!
That's another!
Oh my god, near the night you just killed.
Oh my god, which one?
Oh, the giant arrow man.
Okay, okay, we're figuring it out.
Okay.
Okay, so, there is him.
Alright, which right is it?
Oh, there it is!
Oh my god, it was back here.
Sorry.
Apparently, sorry.
You got- you must- might have- your stream might be a little slow.
Alright.
Now, we got it.
Okay.
Let's sit down.
Do I have enough?
Okay, how much do I need?
26.
Uh...
Okay, we could farm that guy.
Actually, let's see our inventory.
Real quick.
Just to be sure.
800, 2,000... Okay, 2.2...
No, we don't have enough.
I gotta kill him again.
No, I don't have enough runes.
I might have to level up before I go up there.
Just in case.
Just in case something bad happens to me.
Which might be...
Which happens quite often.
I also don't know how much damage he does, to be fair.
Oh shit, I forgot again!
I forgot he does that.
I forgot...
Whoop!
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, that's not fine.
That's not fine.
Let me...
Get down from here.
Oh, okay.
Oh no!
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh, it's not fine.
It's not fine.
Oh my god!
It's okay.
Nice, okay.
Oh, he's just one hit.
I got this.
There we go.
Oh, he gives me 900!
Okay, that's 1k.
Okay, that's fine.
Uh, and then I just need to do like...
23...
Maybe?
Okay, if I get to 23, I should have enough.
Or 20...
2, 3...
Actually, no.
I should have enough right now.
I'll just use up all my runes.
Fuck it.
Oh wait, no!
I have enough right now!
Alright.
Nice, I can't count, guys.
I didn't realize I had 2.
Alright, now I have enough.
Uh...
Alright.
Okay, I don't have enough.
Okay.
Now!
I have enough.
Oh fuck, I still don't have enough.
Okay.
I should have used this one.
Okay, now I have enough.
For now.
Okay.
Alright, what do we get?
What do we get, guys?
Bigger.
Endurance.
Strength.
Okay, we're not doing strength.
Dexterity.
Arcane.
One day.
The problem with trying to give Doki directions of any kind is that she never stops moving for more than one second.
Gladstone.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dexterity?
Okay, we'll do Dexterity.
Alright.
Okay, now we can leave.
Alright, horse.
Come with me!
We're gonna go on a little adventure.
Weeeee!
I don't like today.
My CPU is like going fucking crazy today.
Alright.
Up we go.
Yay!
Okay, we can ride through all of this.
It's fine.
There should be nothing here anyway.
Wait, unless...
Anything here?
No, there shouldn't be anything here.
Alright.
It's fine.
I can just ride through all of this.
Weeeee!
Oh, look.
There's a little buddy of mine here.
Weeeee!
Look at these other big ass horses.
Ha!
But I don't...
There.
Ha!
I...
Did not expect another big ass horse here.
But that's okay.
I got...
Botee!
Hehehe!
Yay!
Can I like...
Go home?
Oh, they got tired.
That's cool.
Ha!
They got...
They got tired, guys.
We're fine.
They got sleepy.
Oh, I still don't have enough?
How much do you need for flask?
Well, I need three.
I only have two.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, I'm gonna grab this item.
And then I...
I'll go challenge them.
Alright.
I'm ready.
Ha!
They think they can win?
Just cuz there's two of them?
Ha ha!
Alright.
That's what they think.
There we go.
We do it here.
And then...
Alright.
Alright, guys.
I need...
Because there's two of them...
Uh...
Ha ha ha!
Because there's two of them, we need as much help as I can get.
Alright.
Ah...
We're min-maxing right here.
Ha ha ha ha!
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm fucking ready, guys.
Get in position, dragoons!
Get in position!
We're ready!
We're so ready now.
That's fucking right.
I can take them now.
I'm not scared.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
What you gonna do now?
You think you can win?
I have... I have jellyfish.
Wait, actually, I can just aggro one guy.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
That's it!
I don't need an army!
I have cheese!
Let's go!
I only have to fight one!
Let's actually go!
Oh my god!
And this one guy is already so fucking strong.
Holy shit.
Maybe I do need cheese.
Oh my god.
What is my jellyfish doing?!
Oh!
Guys!
I'm choking!
What is my jellyfish doing?!
Oh my god!
He can't be in here.
I just...
It's... Oh my god, I just noticed.
I just noticed he can't be in here.
Oh my god.
He can't be in here.
Bro, but I have to fight him here!
Okay.
That's it.
I still got this.
Okay, I can do this without the jellyfish.
It's me and the dragoons.
Dragoons is enough.
What's the dragoons right now?
Me and my dragoons!
Come on!
We can do this!
10v1!
Okay.
Holy shit.
Guys, 10v1!
Okay, that's fine.
Guys, guys, any moment now, any...
Any moment now, guys?
Guys, any...
Any moment, guys?
Come on!
You guys gave me that little message of praise on the goddamn tree!
Any moment, guys!
I'm ready!
I'm so ready, guys!
I'm right here!
Guys, come on!
I'm right here, guys!
Come on!
Whoa!
Oh!
Oh, my God!
No help.
Guys, come on!
We're a team!
What happened to...
I have an army!
Remember that whole speech I had?
Guys, guys, what happened to my speech?
It was so motivational and everything!
Guys, were you not motivated?
Oh, my God.
Come on, guys!
It was so motivational!
Oh, my God.
Just one!
Just one, that's all I ask.
I put two messages down, please.
I...
Oh, no!
Sorry, Doki.
We're on a break right now.
Okay.
I had to shut the lock-in.
Oh, my God.
Finally, somebody found my messages.
They did it!
Oh, my God!
That's fine!
Me and that one dragon!
We got this!
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
I'm living by a thread.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
What the fuck?
He's just...
No!
No, you can't just...
No, no.
No, no, no, no.
You...
I swear to God.
I swear...
I...
I swear to God.
If you still have your HP...
I...
Then he just walks away!
You fucker.
You actual fucker.
I swear to God.
I'm not done with you.
Oh!
Okay.
Maybe I am.
I'm done with you.
I'm...
I'm not getting my runes back.
I'm not going that far up.
All right.
He said...
Come get any water away.
Water, water...
Okay.
I'm...
Maybe I'll try this guy.
Maybe this guy.
Maybe he'll be easier.
Okay.
Maybe.
I'll try this guy.
All right.
We'll try the right side.
Maybe the right side will be easier.
He's the right horse.
Truly the right horse.
Oh my god.
Okay, we'll go with left side.
Left side seems to be the easier one.
Alright, okay, now that we tested both the left and the right horse, I think I relate to the most to the left horse.
Alright.
Yeah, the left sounds good.
The left sounds good.
We got this.
Alright, here we go.
Bum bum bum, and he watered away.
Bum bum bum.
Alright.
Let's go.
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, buddy.
Alright.
Jesus Christ!
Holy fuck!
I need a dodge left for that.
Okay, so...
You know, I would...
I would summon the jelly, but in my area...
There's no jelly here.
I can't get the jelly in here.
Why do I use... I'm so bad with the horse.
I can't fight with the horse.
I'm actually terrible fighting with the horse.
Okay, this time.
Woo!
Okay.
Yeah, I hate the horse combat in this game.
That's why I don't do it.
Oh!
No!
Holy fuck!
Okay.
Oh my god.
That was awkward.
But that's fine.
I'm fine with that.
Holy shit.
Me and my dragoons, we're doing it.
Oh fuck!
Okay, I did not mean to face stack that.
I swear to god.
Oh my god.
And I did not mean to do that either.
I...
Okay, I need to remember not to go too far out.
Okay.
It's fine.
Are you serious?
You're such a bitch!
Oh my god, you're actually such a bitch.
You're such a bitch.
Holy shit.
Okay, we're fine.
Alright.
I still don't know his combos.
Is it obvious?
Nah, right?
There's no way it's that obvious.
Ah!
Fucking hell!
What can I do?
Okay.
I know that combo at least.
We know that one.
They got it.
Oh fuck!
I don't know that one, guys.
I don't know that one.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
We're fine.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
Oh!
Oh my god.
I'm not okay.
Oh!
Oh my.
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, that's not fine!
Oh god, okay.
It's fine.
Please!
I will reinforce this, I swear!
We got it.
Okay.
Alright, one down.
Okay, I'm gonna go back.
Wait, what?
I don't want to get anything out of that.
Do I have to kill two of them?
Wait, I don't get runes?!
I... Okay.
Wait, if I go recover... Guys, if I go back, does he respawn?
Oh my god, he fucking... Oh my god.
He... Oh my god.
He respawns, doesn't he?
Where did he go?!
Where... Where did the other one go?!
Oh my god, he's down there!
Okay, I was gonna be like... Where did... Where did the other one go?!
He just walked down the stairs!
Oh my god, this fucker.
Oh... Okay... Okay... Okay... Can I backstab the horse?
We'll try to find out.
I don't... You cannot backstab the horse... I don't know... I just thought maybe... You know... It was a good effort.
It would've been pretty funny if I could backstab the horse, guys.
It was worth trying.
Holy shit!
My poor jellyfish!
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum!
My poor me!
Poor me!
Okay... Bro, my jellyfish is not okay.
Oh my god, he's not okay, guys.
He's like, literally one hit.
Okay... Jesus Christ!
Please, at least poison him before you die.
That's all I want, buddy.
Watch him die right here.
Oh my god, he did his best.
Oh, I'm gonna get back here a little bit.
Are you serious?
I thought he... Are you serious?!
I thought... Okay, I thought he was gonna get towards me.
I don't know.
I don't... Oh my god.
Oh...
You know, I'll take that.
Maybe he'll bleed, too.
I don't know.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, fuck!
That's not fine.
Oh my god.
Ah!
Fuck!
Okay.
I thought I was gonna die there.
For that.
Oh, ho.
Bum, bum, bum.
Okay.
I'll be full HP just in case, because I don't trust myself.
I really, really do not trust myself.
It's... It's not a good day to be Doki right now.
Oh, fuck!
Okay, I... FUCK!
Not that combo!
Oh, no.
I have one blast left.
Woo!
I miss her.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Okay, we got that combo off.
Oh, not combo, but... You know, at least... Guys, I need... Guys, Doki, thank you.
Guys!
Ah, thank god!
Oh!
Whoa!
I'll use my last blast just in case, because I don't trust myself.
I... Holy shit!
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay!
No!
Okay.
Oh, shit!
No!
No-no-no-no-no-no!
NI-no!
No!
Oh my god.
No, he comes back and he comes back.
Ah!
He even rolled!
I rolled!
But I missed-time the rolled!
Oh!
I give this that close.
Oh, oh my god.
Oh, I rolled too.
No, he's back.
Okay, he's back.
Okay, we... we get back here.
We're in our little house.
Okay, now we're in our little house.
Okay, okay.
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
And this... and this little guy saying thank you for the super chat.
I don't know if I should use my R... my bleed or both my poison.
I don't know.
I don't know which one would work because I feel like he's not getting poisoned at all.
Dude, that's the thing.
Do a bleed?
You should just use your bleed?
Okay, I'll just use my bleed.
Oh, fuck.
I thought I had a tough time to dodge that.
That was my bad.
Okay, I'll just use my bleed then.
Is this attack that fucks me up the most?
Okay.
I got the bleed out once, I saw.
It's this one.
It's this attack!
Time the fucking...
Oh, I always mistim that.
Where's power stancing?
Yeah, should I just two-hand the bleed then?
Alright, I'll two-hand the bleed.
Okay, the L1.
Alright, I'll do...
Oh my god, I hate when they just walk forward.
I hate that.
I'm like, get over here.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I wish I had my AR right now.
I wish I had a gun.
A gun would definitely work right now.
Okay.
Okay, we both missed.
It's not that embarrassing.
It's not...
It's not that embarrassing when we both missed.
Thank god.
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's always this one.
That fuck up on.
Ah!
Jesus Christ.
Fuck you, actually.
Oh, nice.
I got the bleed.
Yeah, see, I get bleed, but...
I haven't seen poison yet.
Holy fuck.
I can't see.
I can't see!
Okay, I need...
Oh my god, please!
I'm blind!
Okay.
Oh my god, he jumps too.
Fuckin' bitch.
Fuckin' what?
Oh my god, I need to stop face tanking that heal.
Are you serious?
Oh, I thought he was gonna do a charge!
I thought he was gonna do a charge!
Turkey, thank you for that one gifted chip.
Thank you, thank you.
Aw!
I thought I was gonna be a charge.
I was ready for a charge!
I got baited.
I got baited so hard.
I do more damage to...
I don't know.
I can't tell.
That's the thing.
I can't tell if I do more damage.
Two-handing or dual-wielding.
Maybe I should try?
I'm gonna try again.
Okay, I'll try dual-wielding this.
Oh my god, I hate you.
I hate you so much!
I hate you.
I hope your mother dies.
Okay, I'm locking in.
Okay.
Oh my god, stop running away!
Jesus Christ.
Getting too far.
Leave his mother out of here.
Why do you guys care so much about the fucking tree sentinel?
What?
Okay.
I have this.
To maybe help me with healing.
On Canada today!
Okay, if anything, I'm pretty sure he's not Canadian.
Guys, I'm pretty sure the tree sentinel is not Canadian, guys.
Okay.
How do you know?
Because Canada doesn't exist in the Elden Ring universe!
There's no Canada here!
Oh my god, he's poisoned.
Oh my god, he's actually poisoned!
How?!
Okay.
The Mounties!
Oh my god, I actually poisoned him!
I don't know how I did it!
I thought poison doesn't exist here!
Oh wait, you guys, message to praise me.
Oh my god, I hate it when he does that.
Oh wait, he's not poisoned anymore.
Wait, he can just get better?
He can just cure himself?
Maybe he is Canadian.
A Canadian healthcare, guys.
He got Canadian healthcare.
Wow!
Okay.
Oh my god, I was gonna roll that!
Dude, that's the thing that sucked the most.
I was about to roll that.
Oh my god, fuck!
Every time he jumps when I'm about to...
Oh, he jumps when I slash.
Goddamn stupid horse.
Alright.
Stupid fucking horse.
Okay.
You're right, it can't be Canada, he'd still be in the office waiting.
You're so right.
Alright.
Here we go.
Here we go again.
It's a stupid horse and he knows it.
That's fucking right.
I did that.
Oh my god, I can actually have time to use my stance too.
That's actually crazy.
That's actually...
Actually...
Oh my god, and he's actually poisoned.
Hold the...
Oh!
Fuck!
Okay.
That's right!
Double poison!
Okay.
Are you serious?
Are you...
Okay, that was bullshit.
That was actually bullshit.
Oh my god, fuck.
Ho ho ho ho ho!
Ho ho!
Yeah, go after my jellyfish, stupid.
Okay, I don't have stances left.
Okay.
Goddamn it.
Oh my god, I'm right here!
Wait!
Jesus Christ.
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
What?!
Oh, that was close.
Holy shit, that was close.
Oh!
Guys, I think I'm fucked.
I'm gonna choke right here.
Watch this.
Oh!
Okay, maybe he'll slowly die of poison.
Guys, I'm not risking it.
I'll just...
I can't wait.
Oh my god, I can wait.
Oh my god, that's right.
Die!
Yeah!
I can't...
There we go.
Alright, with the power of poison by my side.
Let's let it go.
Holy fuck!
We did it!
We did...
Oh, Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Congrats on your victory.
I wonder if this is a bad time to mention there is a more powerful and dangerous variant.
We did it all.
No, I know.
I know.
I've seen Night Ring.
I've seen him in Night Ring.
Don't worry.
I remember him in Night Ring.
Oh my god, it's not even enough to level up.
That's the worst part.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Oh shit, can I actually use this?
Or nah?
Wait.
Is this actually...
Can I actually use this?
Or do I need to save this?
Yeah?
Okay.
Now...
Alright.
Now I can level up.
Alright, guys.
Pick my stat.
Yum, yum, yum.
Time to pick my stat as our favorite game.
It's our...
It's our favorite game.
Pick this.
Oh, Dexterity the...
Dexterity?
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, where do we go now?
New map has been found.
Oh, I guess we go straight here.
I guess so.
Where else would we go?
Alright, let's go straight up.
I don't know where else to go.
Honestly.
Assume it's here.
I don't know why.
Like, it's a...
What the...
Okay.
Does he have...
Okay, he's not even...
You're not even part...
Oh my god.
Bro, you're not even part of the story.
Get out of here.
You're not...
Guys, he doesn't have a boss name.
He's not part of the boss.
I...
You fucker.
I can...
I can run.
Bro, you fucking idiot.
Just summon him again.
Okay, we need that actually.
Oh hey, there's a...
A witch lady.
Hello there, ma'am.
You.
Please.
I can read them.
What?
Your fingers.
Please.
How did you get here?
Okay.
The fingers I served.
Once prophesied.
A tarnished would one day...
That's me!
The Elden Lord.
And restore...
The Golden Order.
Yeah.
Surely you see it too.
She's talking about me, guys.
That's me.
The Great Tree.
Which begets...
The Pillars of Light.
Hasten to the foot of the tree.
She's spoiling the story.
Sorry.
The fingers?
Okay.
I listened to the...
Two toes, man.
Alright, is there any grace nearby, chat?
At chat.
Any grace nearby?
I can't believe she just spoiled a plot like that for us.
No?
Up the slope?
This one?
Or this?
The one?
North side?
Or the...
The east side?
North?
I don't know why I'm like...
Maybe I'll just lower some of the graphics.
Uh...
What do we not need?
Okay, guys.
We're gonna lower something on the...
What do we not need as much?
Less grass?
Alright.
Oh, wait.
That is the less grass.
We can only have like...
Medium?
Or...
Alright.
Okay.
Low.
I don't know why it's staggering a little.
It's not that bad, but...
Uh...
It's still a little annoying.
I did...
I bought a CPU upgrade.
So maybe that'll fi...
I hope that fixes it.
What?
Oh, hi.
Oh shit!
Bye!
Alright, well...
Alright.
I haven't installed it yet.
I haven't...
Uh...
Guys!
I need to find a grace first!
Oh my god.
Did you guys lie about the grace?
Did you guys fucking...
Did you guys...
Where is it?
Oh, it's right here.
Okay, I see it.
It's right here.
Alright, we'll fight him.
I literally just missed it.
Okay.
After I do this.
After I sit down and relax a little.
Oh, I can have flask.
Okay.
Wait, we need the flask.
Okay, nice.
Oh, I wanna talk to her.
Hi!
Eh?
Lady?
The character who vanished long ago.
If you wish, I will share them with you.
Share.
In Marika's own words, hear me, demigods.
My children, beloved, make of thyselves that which he desires.
Here, be it a lord, be it a god, but should ye fail to become aught at all, ye will be forsaken, amounting only to sacrifices.
Cool.
I-I don't really understand, but cool.
That's...
That's a cool story.
Alright, goodbye, m'lady.
Nice talk.
Oh, he comes... Okay, he still pretends...
I-I don't understand why he's still pretending that I didn't see him transforming.
He's like, don't worry.
She won't know.
She won't... She won't know a second time.
There's no possible way she'll know a second time when I transform.
Alright.
Let's...
He's just a little guy.
Guys, don't never know.
I wonder if like...
Okay, I think I...
Maybe if I...
Okay.
I fix the center like this.
Alright, here you go.
Wait, can I not summon?
Oh my god, I can't summon.
Oh my god.
What do you mean I can't summon?
Oh my god, what do you mean?
It doesn't have to be a boss to summon, guys!
Oh my god.
I forgot.
Oh.
Oh shit!
Where am I?
Oh my god, he just throws shit at me!
Shit.
Look, he did something!
What are you doing?
I'm sorry, I'm panicking!
I don't have my jellyfish!
He's gone and I'm scared!
I don't know what to do when...
He's gone!
Oh my god.
I almost forgot to do this.
Okay.
Okay, we did it.
We did it.
Oh, thank god.
First try!
Alright.
It wasn't that bad.
Oh.
Nice.
Okay, everything is okay now.
Yippee!
Wait, where's the...
Grace?
It's right here.
Oh!
Where did I...
Oh my god, it's right here.
Oh my god.
I...
Wait.
Where...
Oh, it's right here.
I'm sorry.
I'm so lost.
I...
I don't know.
The map don't go...
Alright.
Nice.
We're okay now.
Oh, it's good?
Alright.
Let me...
Let me grab...
Grab it.
Really?
Oh, it's stamina!
Okay, that's good actually.
This?
Oh, I can have another.
Nice.
Oh wait, I should...
Should I like...
Put it on that?
Do I want more focus?
Or...
Look at that?
Yeah.
Isn't Vitality good?
This one?
She finally quipped the third one!
Alright.
Alright, we're okay now.
And now we can go up that scary hill.
Equip back the blue...
Yeah, but...
This isn't...
Maximum HP is good.
I get more...
Oh wait, I should go back.
For my HP.
I forgot it doesn't like...
You have to go back.
Did I max my flask?
Oh, I didn't?
Oh shit.
I thought...
No, it's cause I...
I healed one time.
Wait, didn't I already max it up?
Did I not?
What do you mean?
Oh, mixed flask?
Oh!
Fuck!
I forgot about this guy.
We have nothing to mix it with.
I don't even have anything to mix it with.
Okay, it doesn't matter.
I...
I have nothing.
Guys.
Wait, he's back.
Wait, I can farm him.
Wait, he just comes back like that?
Wait, I can farm this guy.
Oh, he's just a regular guy.
Nevermind.
I was like, whoa!
How?
People are just like, how do you have nothing?
Guys, I just...
I don't know.
It's just...
Just the way it is.
It's been...
It's been what?
Five?
Six screams?
Do you not question Toki?
Like...
It literally...
It's just like...
How?
How it comes with one tear?
Honestly, it's impressive.
I don't know.
I just...
It never showed up.
It just never showed up!
I never had to!
Okay?
It never came up!
Okay.
Uh...
I think that's enough, actually.
Should have enough.
For one more upgrade.
Alright, guys.
It's time to help me decide what to get.
What's upgrade.
Yeah.
That should be it.
Alright.
Wait, where's the...
Oh, it's right back up here.
Oh, dexterity to 40.
Okay.
I think that's enough.
Oops, not flask.
Alright.
Alright, let's go.
I assume we deal with the lightning sentinel.
Over there.
Last time I fought that guy, I was the archer.
And that was so easy.
That's the archer.
So, not that.
Castle over here.
Not that.
From up here.
What's up here?
What's up here, though?
It looks so scary.
Oh, is it closed?
Oh!
It cannot open.
Okay.
Alright.
Do we go...
This way?
Or around?
Oh, do we go around?
Like here.
Do we go this way?
This way?
Or...
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Alright, we go around then.
But technically, the tree sentinels are story bosses, right?
Technically, I just defeated a story...
Oh my god, thank god.
I finally defeated a story boss.
Okay, but they are mandatory!
Okay, technically...
Actually, no.
Cause I can just run away.
Nevermind.
I literally...
You can literally just run away from them.
You don't have to fight them.
I forgot.
They are definitely 100% optional.
I guess I follow this pathway.
I assume.
What's that sound?
Can't be that bad, right?
Okay, I feel like I have to go around.
I feel like it's down here.
I don't think it's up here.
Does not seem like a place where I should be.
What is up here?
Oh, there's items.
Okay.
Oh, it's like...
I can't believe they don't guard it.
Oh, fuck!
I thought I was faster!
Oh my god.
Not the trees.
Okay.
It's fine.
I got away.
It's okay.
I still got away.
I was like...
Ha ha!
Dodge this!
Oh yeah.
Another item.
Nice.
We needed that.
And then we'll go down here.
Alright.
And then we go around.
Oh hey!
Free souls!
I thought there's somebody died there.
Somebody died in front of me, but I don't know why.
Oh!
I think I know why.
Okay, now I know.
Now I know how he died.
Okay.
Um...
Ooh!
Guys, I think I know!
I think I know now!
Oh!
God!
Whoa!
Okay.
It's okay.
I'm faster than here.
I...
Oh!
There he is!
I see him!
Hey there, buddy!
Oh!
But there's a cool...
Look at that!
There's a guy over here though!
Okay, I see him.
Oh!
I see him!
There he is!
Look at that little fella!
Oh!
Not very little, but look at him!
There he is!
Whoa!
Oh!
Okay.
What the fuck are you?
Oh my God!
Please do not!
I swear to God!
If you aggro the big ass man over there, I swear to God!
Okay, she's just missing.
Okay.
Oh!
That's fine.
Nice!
Oh my God!
No!
Jellyfish!
Oh.
Oh my God!
Jesus Christ!
Oh!
He does so much!
Guys!
He does so much damage!
I forgot to send up messages!
Oh!
There it is!
Wow!
I'm distracted because she died!
I was like, how did she die?
How did she die?
Oh my god, please.
Holy shit.
I got so distracted, it's not fair.
Oh my god.
Wait, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck.
Oh, I'm stuck!
Guys, message refresh, please, please, please, please, please.
I'm stuck.
I'm actually stuck.
Please.
I'm stuck.
Oh my god.
I thought he was the one that was stuck.
JK.
Silly me.
I was the stuck one in the end.
Oh fuck.
Oh my god.
Okay, I need to heal.
I don't trust myself.
Woo!
Oh my god.
I don't trust myself at all.
Oh no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh!
Okay, I'm focusing.
I'm actually locking it in right now.
Oh my god.
First try!
I'm scared!
Oh my god!
Oh my fucking god!
Oh, I don't know how I did that, right?
We fell.
What, like, it was hard?
I can't believe you guys were so scared of this sentinel.
I can't believe you guys were that scared.
It was pretty easy.
It's pretty fucking... I'm not even gonna meme on ya.
I'm actually impressed.
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, you guys died to that?
Fucking, wow.
That guy took me three hours.
Like it was hard?
That was pretty easy.
Alright, we did a story boss, guys.
We fucking did it.
I'm sure you don't have the right.
Oh, you don't have the right.
Be wary of drag.
I don't wanna hear...
Everyone stop appraising till you...
What?
Oh, I'm sorry.
Skill dip.
I don't wanna be salty as you got dipped by an anime girl.
Give me back my congratulations.
I don't know her ego.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki failing multiple times at regular tree sentinel.
Just the first try to trick Koenig one.
Doki moment.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, come on.
I don't mean that.
Guys, I love your appraisals.
Guys, come on.
I couldn't have done it, guys.
Without your appraisals.
Come on.
Alright.
Let's get this finger remedy.
Too late.
I demand appraisal refund.
Behold, city.
Ooh.
Oh, wait.
Is it... Is it... Was it the...
Irwood tree or something?
Your tree.
Would this be a traitor or a friend?
Oh.
I don't think I should do anything.
Dog.
I...
That's fucked up.
That's a person.
Holy shit.
Just getting started.
Wait, how did these guys die?
Okay.
Yeah, that makes sense.
Or just be a head.
Bro, bro.
This guy just went like...
Stupid ass man.
He slipped.
Be wary of a head.
Why is there always recklessness?
Oh, hey.
There's a grace, though.
He tripped.
Don't listen to anyone, Stokey.
You're the best Elden Ranked player in history.
I kneel.
I never remembered that you were in the super chat.
Thank you.
Nice.
Alright, let's go this way.
Oh, wait.
That's so beautiful.
Wait.
Could this be Elden Ring?
Wait, is that...
Is that Elden Ring?
Hahaha.
That's so pretty.
Why is this city...
Oh, never mind.
I was gonna say.
This city looks like...
Untouched and everything.
Are they bad?
I mean, they seem...
They seem like good people.
Hi.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, never mind.
Bad.
No.
Don't you do that again.
Doot.
Yeah, she killed me with the doots.
She did a doot.
Doot doot.
Okay, Fred wouldn't do that, though.
Not Fred.
If Fred...
Why is she doot on me?
Didn't expect lovable sword.
The doot squad.
Doot a doot.
Oh my god.
She's a big dude.
Oh, shit!
Oh!
Okay, we both missed out.
That was embarrassing for both of us again.
That's fine.
We both embarrassed ourselves today.
And that's okay.
Yeah!
Oh, nice.
We got Golden Rune.
The huge doot.
Doot doot.
Dog ahead.
This guy?
That's a woman.
Oh my god!
What happened?!
Okay.
She's a TP.
Oh no!
Yeah, no.
That's a dog.
Nevermind.
Oh yeah, that's...
Yeah.
Okay, um...
Okay.
Nevermind.
That...
No.
Yeah, that's the dog, guys.
There she is.
What?
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck do I do?
My dog can't do that.
What?!
How hip went wall?!
Okay, let me go down from here.
I'll do this, and then...
Wait, not...
Okay, I'm fine.
What the fuck?
Why was I scared?
Just do that.
Alright.
Nice.
We did it.
Still no high road.
What's over here?
Oh!
Wait, is this shortcut?
What's this?
Try target law?
No.
No?
Wait, was this the way to go then?
Oh, I keep forgetting to put my lantern on.
Oh, hey.
Whoa!
It's like...
Hey, buddy.
I don't know.
I thought...
For some reason, I was like...
Friend?
I don't know why.
I don't know.
I don't know, guys.
I keep...
I'm too friendly.
I...
He's like...
Home Invader!
Sorry.
I invaded this man's home.
I...
I just...
Oh.
Oh, that's sad.
Oh, my God.
He's actually limbless.
This...
Oh, my...
Don't worry.
I freed him.
I freed this man.
He doesn't have to live.
Oh, shit.
There's a dragon over there.
He can't turn, Toki.
I freed him!
What was...
He was gonna suffer anyway.
Now he's in heaven, guys.
No, he can no longer...
Be in pain.
Don't worry, everyone.
I freed him.
Yeah.
He killed an unarmed man.
What the fuck is wrong with me?
Guys!
I freed him from his...
From his physical prison.
Okay?
From his mortal prison.
He's in heaven now.
Okay, guys?
He was suffering.
I freed him.
I let him.
He doesn't have to suffer.
Oh, my God.
It's a perfumer, man.
It's a perfumer.
All right.
There you go.
Bye, perfumers.
No more perfume for you.
Okay, we go this way.
Okay.
Actually, I don't think I need to use the special ones.
All right.
Listen carefully.
Why is there always sadness?
Oh, like the doots?
The doot-a-doots?
Okay, get these guys out of the way.
Or not.
They don't deserve to smell good.
Where do I go?
There's so many areas to go.
Let's get rid of these guys, though.
Oh.
Ooh, item.
Yeah!
Kill him first.
And then, like...
I'll leave.
Oh, fuck!
Okay, I guess I don't leave?
Question?
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
I don't have enough.
It's fine.
I can do this.
Whoa!
Ha, ha, ha, ha!
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Oh, my God!
That's cheating!
Stupid fucking nerd.
That's cheating, you nerd!
Oh, my God.
That's stupid nerding.
Oh, my!
I was trying to roll.
Jesus Christ.
I hate these guys so much.
Yeah.
All right.
It's fine.
I still have flasks.
Ha, ha, ha!
God damn it.
Are you serious?
I'm in a confined area!
Oh, my God.
Okay, we got him.
Oh, we got him.
Oh, wait.
This guy has...
Oh, nice bleed.
That's fine.
Ha, ha, ha!
I have bleed!
That's ra- Oh, shit!
Oh, no!
No.
No, no, no.
Oh, my God, he scared the shit out of me.
Oh, shit!
That guy scared the shit up...
Oh, he has armors?
All right.
There we go.
That's fine.
Ohh!
Oh, we did it.
We did it.
Okay.
Last blast.
Alright.
Can't believe it.
I came to his home and he's here to... Alright.
Where is he?
Oh, there you go.
I'm fucking 13.
I'm sorry.
Bush ahead.
Where?
Okay.
Okay, bro.
Oh, here?
Okay, but I need grace.
I need grace so badly right now.
Is there any grace nearby?
Holy fuck.
That was not very nice.
Okay, no door ahead.
Okay.
I'm, like, a little worried right now.
You where I left?
Oh.
Haha!
You thought I didn't see you.
Hahaha!
And now that you helped me, sir.
Now... Now that you've helped me.
I...
Alright.
Where is it?
Places.
Affinity.
Concept.
Direction.
Situation.
Guys, I'm trying to find a very specific thing here.
Teacher.
Lover.
Ain't wicked.
Oh, there you go.
Liar.
There you go.
Now make sure you downvote this message.
And then upvote that.
Oh, fuck.
Fuck.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
At least he doesn't have electricity.
Oh.
Message appraise, please.
Please.
I'm not okay.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Oh no!
For the service.
No.
No!
Okay.
I got it.
We're...
We're now okay right now.
Oh my god!
Okay.
Alright, well, we can wait.
Guys, who the fuck is the closest?
Grace!
What the fuck?
Oh my god, I hear him.
Wait, where am I?
Where did I go?
Wait.
Guys, look at my HP!
Yeah, do you think it is wise for me to go?
Pass the tree with the big ass guy that fucking floated from above?
Okay, guys, please.
Guys.
Please, I...
Please, I need one.
Just...
Just one.
Please, I just...
I need one, please.
I just need one, guys.
Guys, look at me.
I'm so fucked up right now.
Guys, does this look like a person?
That's doing okay?
Do it for us.
Okay.
Okay, I'm ready.
I'm so ready.
Is it here?
Oh, shit.
Okay, we're not supposed to be here.
We're...
Okay, no.
He can...
He can stay there.
I...
Fuck you.
I'm not dealing with that.
Anyone appraise this yet?
Come on, please.
Oh, my God.
I don't have my horse.
Guys, my horse.
This is...
Guys!
Please, please, guys.
Please, I have so much...
I have so much money, guys.
You don't want me to get robbed in Crime City.
Guys, I...
Please, I don't want to get robbed in Crime Alley, guys.
Oh, there's a healing gem in my inventory.
Okay, I believe.
Okay, I figured it out.
Okay, there's a healing gem.
Okay, I just need a...
Okay.
I have a healing gem.
Okay, what does it look like?
What does it look like?
Where is it?
A gem.
It looks like a gem.
That's okay.
Thank you.
Okay, is it this?
What else could it look like?
Is it this?
How do I use it?
Oh my god, I have no mana.
Oh my god, I don't have it.
I don't have mana for this.
I am...
Okay, it's fine.
We can run past this.
Guys, I just...
Guys, come on.
I just...
One of you...
Guys, I will give you a shout-out.
I will...
If I get one message appraised.
Come on.
Just one.
I'm okay.
Oh my god.
Guys, I think he's gonna fucking kill me.
Oh!
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
I do not deserve that.
Oh!
My god!
I don't need you!
I'm kidding!
I'm screaming!
That's fucking right!
That's right message.
I praise the...
Hello.
My utmost thanks for bringing me to the base of the earth.
There we go.
I did it.
That's...
I keep right message.
I praise this!
I...
Wait.
Who will upgrade my stuff?
Farewell.
I shall leave Torrent.
And the power to turn runes into strength.
Oh, thank god.
I was gonna say, who the fuck is gonna upgrade?
Ungrateful.
No, wait.
Don't leave me!
No doubt, you will become Elden Lord.
May you take the throne.
Oh, hey, Maxxer.
Johnny, thank you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What is...
What is that?
Anyway, where...
Where...
Where is she from?
Ashes of War?
No.
I don't even know what...
What did you do?
I don't even remember.
I...
She's gone, bro.
Oh, shit.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, was she the one that leveled me up?
Okay.
Okay, clearly I was...
Sorry, I had too many Maidens that it was hard to keep track.
Core.
Alright.
No, guys, I just had too many Maidens that it was so hard to keep track, guys.
Of, like, which...
What she did.
Oh, my God.
Jesus.
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
Let's just sneak up.
They won't know.
Oh,
fuck!
I didn't mean that!
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I'm...
I'm okay, guys.
Oh, fuck!
Oh, shit!
I don't...
Guys, I don't...
I don't think I'm getting any message of praise, aren't I?
I...
I'm so serious.
I have a feeling that...
Maybe my drag wounds aren't gonna praise me anymore.
I...
Oh, my God.
I'm dead!
What do you want from me?
You said you didn't need it.
Guys, guys, I was joking.
It was...
It was for content, guys.
Come on, come on, come on.
God, you...
You know you wanted to...
Oh, look at that.
Thank you.
Thank you for the...
Message of praise, chat.
I really appreciate that.
Thank you, guys.
This is for content.
Oh, fuck.
What?
That's awkward.
Union rules.
Sorry.
Papa, sir, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Sir, thank you for the super chat.
Does he know?
Oh, he knows.
Okay, but I have the high ground.
Come on.
Yeah.
What was he gonna do?
I literally have the high ground.
That's right.
Challenge me.
Are you scared?
Oh, you're scared.
I fucking knew it.
Wait.
I figured it out.
Watch this.
Okay, I hope that doesn't hit me.
That's right.
I didn't watch this.
Come on.
Challenge me.
I have the high ground yet again.
You don't know how to walk up...
Oh, he's...
Oh.
You don't know how to walk upstairs.
That's right.
What you gonna do?
Oh, shit.
He's walking up the stairs even more.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
That's right.
Oh, my God.
He's up here.
I didn't think this far.
I...
Guys.
I didn't think this far.
I didn't think he'd come up here.
Oh, my God.
Guys.
I...
Why is he here?
Oh, my God.
Why are you here?
Oh, fuck.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I thought he turned around.
That was like my entire plan.
That was like... I thought he... he turned around!
He did that the first time!
He killed you.
I thought he would turn around!
Okay, okay.
I figured it out.
He spared you the first time.
I don't understand.
Why didn't he turn around?
He is no coward.
Okay.
I got it.
And then he'll do it the second.
He'll turn around the second.
He he he.
He he.
That's right.
He he he he.
Don't you ever learn.
Raxi.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, now.
Now I'm out of the high ground.
Is he coming over?
I'm out of the high ground.
He he he.
Ahh-ha!
That's right!
Oh fuck!
Oh shit!
Guys I didn't hit it.
Okay.
Like, he knows.
Guess he doesn't see me.
All according to... All according to... He doesn't know.
Forget about me, right?
Alright.
Alright, round three.
Oh!
Holy shit!
He bit him!
He's shame on me!
Fooled me twice!
Oh my god, he's actually running!
Holy... He did not forget.
Oh my god, he actually ran.
He could tell.
He cut the eye out his nose.
It's okay if Crouch, he'll turn around.
Oh my god, he's actually... He's slowly backing up with his shield out!
Oh!
I'm getting closer!
Oh my god!
What?
What do you mean they can learn this much?
Oh my god!
Bro, that's fucked up.
That's actually... That's actually... That's actually fucked up, buddy.
Okay.
Clever boy.
I... I... Nobody told me they can actually learn!
Oh my god!
I'm stuck!
He got it!
He got me stuck!
Okay, we're getting out of here.
I'm not fighting them anymore.
Okay.
Alright.
They won.
They've won.
I'm not fighting.
Okay.
I'll do one last backstab on that guy.
I didn't think I'd be stuck!
I didn't heal because I thought I'd be okay.
Okay, I'll do this.
Grab this!
And then leave.
Okay.
Here we go.
We're fine now.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you for the message of praise.
Thank you guys.
Alright.
I've learned my lesson.
I'm not going through that guy.
I'm not doing that.
I didn't hit you.
They've won.
I'm not going through that.
Precious item ahead?
Oh.
We need that.
What's over here?
No secret passage.
Okay.
That's not the way.
Oh, hey!
There's the dragon!
There he is.
And where is Zoe?
Try jumping?
Okay.
No.
Not here.
Maybe like...
There's a ladder here.
Snakes and ladders?
Anton!
Thank you for the super...
Uh, thank you for the one gifted ship.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm sorry.
I feel like that's a fair reaction, guys.
Oh, I'm calling the dragon?
Nice.
Is he dead or is he sleeping?
Alright.
I can't tell.
He dead?
Why don't they just get rid of this dragon?
What's he doing here?
How do I get out of here?
Oh, he's petrified.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
How do you just remove a dragon from all of this?
I guess here?
Oh, nice.
I don't know.
You can just, like, start cutting it into pieces.
That's a neat thing.
You don't.
You wear a strong flow.
First off, well done.
I didn't!
Huh?
Oh my god, no.
No.
No, not these guys again.
Oh my god.
Just stab him.
I just...
No, I shouldn't.
I shouldn't test my luck.
Look at the fact.
I don't trust you guys to save me anymore.
I may or may not have...
I might have, like...
Oh wait, did he hear me?
Oh shit!
I don't think you guys will save me.
You'll let me die to teach me a lesson.
Okay.
What does it say?
I wanna read your message.
You're stupid.
I wanna read your fucking stupid message.
I'm curious.
Goddammit, I'm not that curious.
Okay, she doesn't trust us.
Okay.
I swear to god.
Alright.
I swear, I swear to god.
I'll fight him.
But I swear to god.
Oh shit, he did...
I can't believe it worked a second time.
Me too.
Alright.
Am I gonna get help?
Dragoons?
Am I...
Guys, am I gonna get help?
Huh?
Am I...
Alright.
Time to find out.
Will I get help?
Come on.
Come on!
Alright!
Come on guys!
I'm r...
Guys!
Guys, guys!
I'm right here!!
Guys!
The message apprais.
Whoa!
Guys!
He's stabbing me!
He's stabbing me guys!
He....
Okay!
He's still stabbing me!
Guys!
Oh my god, he does it twice now?
Oh my god.
No!
Oh,
yeah, yeah, greed.
Yeah, yeah, greed.
That was it.
Guys, that was... that was the issue.
Yeah, okay.
Message was a break.
Alright, let's grab this and leave.
Your greed sickens me.
You're dead.
No, not big surprise.
Raksha, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Nervous.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh.
Oh, they're like mourning something.
So there's speed.
Blocking.
Thanks for all the laughs and smiles.
Is this precious item ahead?
Oh, there it is.
Do you have a favorite candy?
Oh, Lindit chocolates.
I love Lindit.
The chocolates.
Chocolate.
Latte.
Oh.
Oh, da da pom pom.
Chocolate misto.
Pa da dum.
Pam pum.
Hi.
But those are my favorite.
Down ahead.
But first off... Lever?
Get it out of my head!
Where's the lever?
You said there was a lever here.
Where?
The fuck is this lever?
Am I blind?
Where is this man po- Oh my god, I am.
It's literally- Okay, that literally blended into the surroundings.
You can't blame me on that.
A lever.
As I do though.
Where is this lever?
I don't know what this lever is doing.
Oh, it's this door!
Oh!
Oh, okay, I can make this jump.
Actually, I don't think I can.
Okay, there's no red patches.
So I think I can.
Maybe if I'm full healed.
Maybe if I'm... Guys, how about we coordinate?
Okay, I got an idea.
When I hit the ground, we coordinate message appraises.
So, oh wait, I can just go for it.
From there.
Wait.
Okay, wait.
I can just go from there.
Okay.
Never mind, guys.
Never mind.
I can literally drop down from here.
There we go.
You almost got me.
You almost got me, guys.
Look at you.
Look at me go.
First off, good luck.
And then try skill.
Grace ahead.
Seek right.
Oh, okay.
I don't like this bomb this way.
Where the fuck?
Oh, it's over here.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, I was gonna be like, where the fuck is this grace?
All right.
Okay, nice.
Made it pretty far.
What's this?
Oh.
Got another painting.
Let's go.
Notice what?
First off, good luck?
Now I notice it.
I just felt like something's gonna kill me.
If I take it.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Wait, I get to take this for free?
Oh, shit.
Nice.
I like free stuff.
For free?
Nice.
Oh, my God.
I don't get punished for it, too?
Okay, I legitimately thought I was gonna fucking...
Something was gonna, like, come up and slap me or something.
That's nice.
I'm so paranoid.
Of course I'm paranoid.
It's Elden Ring.
It's a Souls game.
It's this way.
They're all out to get me.
I can feel it.
They all want a piece of me.
Oh, two fingers.
Nice.
Well, I'll never know what that message says.
Okay, nice.
What are you gonna do?
Fucking throw food at me, bro.
That's sad.
So sad.
Doki, they were just kitchen workers.
I can't believe it.
Killing the hell?
How far are you falling?
Only two?
Sometimes three is pretty good, too.
Ladder ahead?
I don't know.
Wait, there is?
Where is it?
Come on.
I am blind, but like...
Huh?
You only had a friend.
Where is this message point?
Where you pointing to, sir?
Oh my god!
Oh, you fucker!
You... God!
No, you fucker.
So good.
That's so good.
Okay, I have...
Okay, you...
I...
I also gotta help out.
I have to help him out, too.
Okay.
Where the fuck is ladder?
Wait!
Is that...
Oh, wait.
Okay, these are my appraisals.
I...
Look at that.
No porn messages.
Look at that, guys.
Okay, how do I...
How do I add, like...
Uh...
Um...
A...
Emote to it.
I forgot.
It's been so long.
Is it Y?
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Alright.
I shall also help you out.
Hahaha.
Okay.
Detour?
Enemy ahead?
Strong foe ahead?
Hello?
Oh, my God.
The fact that it slowly walked forward.
Oh, don't eat me!
Please!
Hahaha.
Okay.
It's fine.
I can run past all of this.
Oh, wait.
My item.
Woo!
Got item, though.
Ah!
Hahaha.
That's on me.
I got greedy.
Alright.
We made it.
Hahaha.
She can't go through doors.
Holy shit.
I thought she was gonna come over.
I thought she...
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
When she slowly approached me, I thought I was not fine.
But it's okay.
I'm fine.
Why does it always seems familiar?
What is...
Ah.
That's a boss bite right here.
Hahaha.
Oh, thank God.
There's a grace.
Nice.
Okay.
Let's...
Let's stay here for a little bit.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be right back, chat.
Alright.
I'm back.
Okay.
Let me check something real quick.
Some hydration.
Hmm.
Senator, Chris, Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
Powerball, Nexi, Mike, Neera, Solid, Snake, Bite, Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
I feel like we should upgrade our stuff because it has been a while.
Let's go back.
Let's go back to see if there's like anything we can upgrade real quick.
Um, Yaku, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yes, I washed my hands, guys.
Of course I did.
Uh...
Oh, I don't have that.
I don't have a level six.
I don't know what I need.
Oh, I need one more level four Smithing Stone.
Ah...
Fuck, I don't know if it's worth it yet.
Okay, but like...
Do I really need a filler?
Another filler?
Guys.
We traveled so far already for no filler today.
We traveled so far without a filler episode.
Okay.
The next...
Where is the next mine?
Where do I go?
If I do do a mine, where is it?
Where is it?
We'll do one filler.
Where do...
Oh my god, I don't even know where I came from.
Okay, we're gonna figure out where I was, too, after this.
I actually don't remember.
Okay, where is the...
Where is the...
Is it this one?
Is it this mine?
No?
Which one is it?
Is it this one?
There's one that lets you like...
Uh...
Buy...
Oh, this one?
Okay.
So which one was the one that lets you buy stones later?
Though.
Is this one?
Okay.
Alright, we'll go here.
Actually, I don't know if that's the one where I can go.
Actually...
We go here?
Actually, we should go here.
And then walk up here, right?
Yeah.
I should go from here.
I was gonna say, I'm pretty sure I have to go through a boss fight.
Ha ha ha!
Okay, it's...
Should be this way.
Okay, we should actually march shit down now.
Alright.
Okay, let's go.
Oh my god.
We're Soling, guys.
We're Elden Ringing.
We're so good at this game.
Look at us go.
We're becoming...
We're Elden Ringing now.
Oh, hey.
Dude.
Hello.
Goodbye.
Grease?
The fuck are these woes doing with Grease?
Okay.
I think this is how you go down.
Yeah.
We're doing it, guys.
We're Elden Ringing.
On the...
I'm John Elden!
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh my god, guys.
I'm John Elden now.
Alright.
Go this way.
Okay, there's the mines.
There it is.
No, that wasn't so hard.
Literally, right there.
Goodbye, horse.
Goodbye.
Oh, I hear the miners.
I'm yearning for those mines.
How do I get that?
Oh, there...
Fucking knew it.
I knew it.
I was like, why is there a random indent?
I know what you are.
Ha ha ha ha.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god.
I forgot that they don't do pierce.
Oh!
Come on!
Is that fair?
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Just beat me up.
Okay, this is awkward cause...
I need to figure out like...
Ha ha ha ha.
I don't have...
Actually have a weapon for these guys.
I have to use two hands?
What the fuck?
Oh my gosh.
Short King.
Let's go.
Okay.
These guys don't care.
That's fine.
I'm not looking to get these.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh!
Shit!
What the fuck are you gonna blow fire?
Oh shit!
He is gonna blow fire!
I was like, what you shaking your lantern for?
Stupid!
Oh my god.
Okay.
Nice.
Yeah, I picked up the chest earlier.
I'm pretty sure I did.
Alright?
I'm gonna go check it again.
Oh my god.
It opened it and I was like, bye.
Ha ha ha!
I'm only here for the thrill of opening chests.
That's my thrill.
Has to be like...
Okay, it's a sealed tunnel.
So if there's a hole, there's a gold.
Oh my god.
Is it back here?
It's back here.
It's next to the chest.
Clever, girl.
Alright.
And path ahead.
Behold attacking.
There's like 200 messages for this hidden path.
Alright.
Here I am.
Not so hidden, is it?
Try sword.
Fucking nah nah, nerd.
That's right.
Try to make me be a fucking nerd.
Get out of here.
Whoa!
My god!
Oh shit!
Oh my god.
There's so many of them.
Holy shit.
What?
Like I can't see you?
Like...
What are you gonna do?
Throw smoke at me?
Okay, I'm okay guys.
I'm...
I'm okay.
That was a little scary.
But I'm okay.
Go back to school.
Who let these kids here?
A pocket set.
Be wary of explosion.
Here.
What is here?
What do you mean here?
Oh my god.
It's literally right here.
It's...
Bro, what the fuck do I do?
Oh!
That's what he meant by here!
Didn't get me.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
I was like, what the fuck does he mean here?
Oh, nice item.
Okay.
I need this though.
Yoink!
Explode!
To be fair, I thought that I was far enough.
To be fair.
I...
I didn't think I was that close.
I was like...
Explode on me.
What's gonna happen to me anyway?
Nothing.
In the end something happened.
Trap ahead?
Okay.
Okay, nice.
And then hidden.
Nice.
Jesus Christ.
How many areas are there?
Oh no.
Okay.
I should fall in the center.
God.
This is way too much.
Okay, how important is that though?
Can't be that important.
Woo!
Made it.
Try item.
Try jumping.
Okay, but is that...
I can't...
I don't believe it's that important.
I refuse to believe that item is important.
It's not.
You can't fucking bait me.
I know it's not important.
I know it's not.
Therefore likely rolling.
Okay, but where the fuck do I drop down?
Here?
Do I live if I drop down here?
Doki, you have to go there.
That's where the Elden Ring is.
Doki, you're missing the Elden Ring.
The Elden Ring is literally right there.
You can end the game right now if you get it.
Oh.
This looks like a boss fight.
But then this also looks like danger.
Dead end ahead.
Could this be rolling?
Something?
Something ahead?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I fucking...
Okay.
Okay, me and no.
Okay, he's naked.
He can't be that good.
He's naked.
Okay.
Oh shit!
What the fuck did he do?
Oh my god.
What did he do?
Oh shit!
He's a nerd.
But he's naked.
He's naked.
What?
Okay, every time I get close.
Oh!
Okay.
Are you serious?
Who are you?
Fuck.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I fucked it up.
Oh shit!
Okay, nice.
Okay, I got him.
I got him.
It's fine.
It's okay.
Nothing to worry about.
I did it.
Easy as hell.
Not even close.
Let's go.
Oh hey, there's a grease.
First try.
First fucking try.
My mini filler episode.
Oh hey, there's the other tree.
Three ahead.
Tree.
Nice.
There's the tree.
Alright.
Where is this?
Seek something incredible or dead end.
What's this?
Is this the Elden Ring?
Hello?
Behold, I did it.
Oh my god.
Am I gonna get the Elden Ring?
Hello?
Ooh.
Look at all the pretty...
Whoa!
Message of praise.
Thank you.
I mean, look at all these shagging rocks.
Oh my god.
I could have leveled up.
Okay, that's fine.
I'm clear.
I'm pretty sure there's no boss battle here.
I'm pretty sure it's just pretty rocks.
Oh, it's another grace.
Where the fuck am I?
I...
I'm at a weird part.
I accidentally got into a filler episode.
So I don't know where I am.
Okay.
Let's get...
I should be able to level up.
Alright.
Level up.
And then...
Dexterity.
Yes, I'm not gonna jump.
I'm not...
What is this place?
Hello?
Wait, what?
What is this for?
I don't know what I did.
Oh!
I got Rykard's great rune.
Cool!
Visions of fire.
I did it!
Is that...
Oh my god!
Is that the other ring?
Did I do it?
Alright, now...
Now...
I should be able to...
Buy some stuff.
Alright, now I should be able to upgrade shit now.
You did it!
A tree!
I took you for no matter.
Stay out your arm.
Every time he thinks I died.
Okay.
I still don't have enough.
So that means...
I have to go back.
Give the bell to the lady.
And then buy more runes.
And then go back to him.
Upgrade my sword.
And then go back to the main storyline.
Oh.
Hello.
Okay.
Was it three?
That's three, right?
Okay.
Oh fuck, it wasn't three.
It was four.
I can't count.
It's four.
Okay, let me pop some runes real quick.
Hello.
M'lady.
I'm just popping some runes.
There's three and four.
I'm back.
You're looking pretty.
You're looking pretty young, ladies.
Oh my god, is that your sister?
Whoa.
You guys don't look a day over a thousand.
Yeah, but I think I need one for each.
I wonder how many runes I need after.
I have stones I need for this.
No matter.
Okay, we'll grab this.
Oh my god, I can just keep going.
Okay.
Uh...
And then...
I need...
Six of three.
Okay.
And then...
We should be good.
Okay.
Six of three.
Oh.
Wait.
I need...
Fuck.
Crack up some more runes.
And I need more, right?
I don't have a lot.
Fuck is it?
Oh, there it is.
Alright.
Wait.
Is plus 14 good?
Oh, nice.
Fuck yeah.
We need five of this.
Alright.
So we can upgrade our poison.
Upgrade my sword.
Sir?
Alright.
And then...
Um...
Is it worth...
Fuck it.
Let's keep upgrading.
Alright.
So we should grab more.
Fuck it.
We might as well.
Alright.
I'm back.
We need four, right?
Grab ten.
I think it was ten, right?
It was two, four, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine...
Yeah, ten.
Wait.
I need two more.
I can't count.
Whoops.
Sorry.
I'm not counting, right?
Boop.
I can buy another one.
Alright.
And then...
Now!
I should be able to upgrade my poison katana.
There we go.
Here I go.
I went through...
One ep...
One and a half episode of this failure for this.
Oh my god.
I'm broke again.
Jesus Christ.
Pop!
Alright.
I'm always back.
I'm always back for more.
Eh, fuck it.
Let's go.
Alright.
Now we're good to go.
Now...
Now we're...
Now we're cheeked up.
We're ready.
Okay, here.
The vine bridge.
Alright.
Time for the boss fight.
How bad can I be?
I'm just doing what's unnecessary.
Oh, it's not summable.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god.
You're not even a boss fight.
Oh, shit!
Oh shit!
Okay.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, it's so delayed!
It's not fair!
It's fine.
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
Whoa!
I don't know, maybe I'll poison fuck a rock.
Maybe...
Why is it a rock?
I don't know.
Okay, it's fine.
He's dead.
It's fine.
It's dead.
I don't know if it was worth killing him, but I think he's... I think he'll come back.
Wait, he doesn't even give me anything.
Wait, what?
You don't even give me anything?
Oh my god.
Your life has no meaning.
I can't believe it.
His life actually has no meaning.
Alright, nice.
I have a... Oh, yippee.
I guess.
Ooh.
Oh, wait.
Actually, wait.
Actually, no.
This is yippee.
Oh, wait.
Yippee.
Oh my god.
This is yippee.
Wait a minute.
It actually goaded.
Look at that HP go up so fast, Doki.
What?
What do you mean?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Where am I supposed to go?
I don't have...
What am I supposed to...
Oh, it's always the tree.
It's...
Dude, that tree.
Why is it always the pocket tree?
Alright.
Where is the closest?
Is it here?
Okay.
Capital.
It's up the dragon?
I didn't do the right dragon parkour?
Where am I?
Oh, it's up here.
Okay.
It's here.
Did you just go straight?
Just go straight then, right?
Oh!
Those tree roots.
Okay.
I just gotta do that again.
Oh my god.
I lived.
Time to climb the tree to get to a big tree.
Alright.
Here we go.
Climb the tree to get to a big tree.
Coming over, Mr. Big Tree.
Is he a bad person?
Oh no.
They're tree men.
Oh wait, they're weak.
Okay, thank god.
Okay, thank god they're weak.
Oh, thank god.
Alright, get him out.
Oh shit.
Hey there.
Oh my god.
No, he drops poison!
Okay, it's fine.
Okay.
Your buddy's dead.
Goodbye.
Alright, it's fine.
We're still fine.
What the fuck?
What are you doing?
It's just chilling up there.
Oh shit.
I thought they lined up for me.
I'm not gonna lie.
It literally looks...
Oh shit!
Oh my god.
I'm gonna fall.
Okay, but it actually looked like they were just gonna line up for me.
Oh no.
It's fine.
It's okay.
I'm just a little poison.
Oh, apparently these guys don't attack.
The ones with no flowers.
It's fine.
I'm just a little poison.
Doesn't hurt nobody.
You know what?
I want the extra souls.
Get over here.
That's right.
That 500?
Yummy, yummy.
Good enough.
Alright.
Okay, you have a flower.
You must die.
No flower for you.
Tarnish required ahead.
Boss ahead.
Good luck.
Oh shit.
Maybe I shouldn't have got poison.
Shit.
Okay.
Alright.
Well, that's too bad.
I have to live with my consequences.
I guess.
I...
Oh shit.
I don't...
Oh my god.
It's you.
Oh shit.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
That was a...
That was a mistake and a half.
That guy...
Guys, no I can't.
I...
Okay.
I wasn't ready.
Mentally I was not there.
I was not there.
Mentally my head was not there.
I have to admit.
I...
I was not.
I think the poison hit hard there.
The...
It was...
It was the poison guy.
I swear to God.
It was the poison.
Oh my god, let me grab this real quick.
Okay, how fucked is my jellyfish?
Oh, she's okay.
She's so healthy.
Oh my god, there you go.
Okay,
we're fine.
We're okay for now.
Wait, can I not?
Can I not do a backstab on this guy?
Is it because he's a ghost?
Why is it?
Oh, I... oh my god.
Oh, nice.
Got the crit.
I was gonna say, why can't I backstab the ghost?
Can ghost bleed?
Wait, that's a good question.
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck!
I'm sorry, I'm fucking around too much!
Holy shit!
Wow!
Okay, that's cool.
What is the range?!
What is the range for your fucking weapon?!
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
You're not even real!
Oh my god, you're not even real!
Yes!
Holy shit!
Yeah, we did it!
Okay.
No, there are ranges!
Yes!
I didn't expect the real...
The real one.
Oh my god.
Okay, thank god.
Okay.
We're good.
We're okay.
Alright.
You know what?
I'll call...
We're calling it here.
We have two streams today.
We're calling it...
That's a...
That's a story boss!
We did two story bosses, guys!
That's...
Holy shit!
And we got the low...
Okay.
That was good.
That's...
There's one more!
That's for next week, Doki.
They deal with...
That's...
We have a packed week this week.
Uh...
That...
We did two...
We technically did two story bosses.
Guys.
Technically.
Yeah.
Two...
Two whole story bosses.
Cindy, thank you for Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Good job, Doki.
Two tries.
I'm so proud of you.
Thank you, guys.
You guys saw how I first tried Tree Set all day?
Oh, man.
Those are good times.
Anyway, so...
Tonight, we're gonna have another stream tonight.
It's gonna be a sponsored stream with Mecha Break.
So, um...
Um...
You guys wanna support the stream and, uh...
Support the game and me, uh...
Come over on Twitch at 9pm PSC.
It's gonna be 9pm PSC on Twitch for Mecha Break.
And it's gonna be the Mecha Break launch, too.
Um, so you guys wanted to check out Mecha Break anyway.
Um, it is the launch day for it at 9pm.
PSC.
Hey, guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
Uh, because we're gonna do a second stream anyway.
And, uh...
Uh, you know.
We already did a long first stream on YouTube.
And we're gonna do another two...
At least two hour stream, uh, tonight.
Hey, guys.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Pause your check.
Get up and move around to get that...
Oh my god.
Of course you guys message appraise me now.
You guys are like, It's time!
It's time!
She's...
We've withheld all these message appraise.
Now it's time to message...
I think she learned her lesson.
Now we can message appraise her.
Hey, guys.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Pause your check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you said for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!